le charme du centre ville de Bourges est
connu de tous les touristes des rues
pavées des maisons en panne bois et
d'énormes soupiraux derrière ces grilles
on peut y découvrir de superbes caves
isabelle a découvert la sienne par
hasard
et le plan biais m'a dit que en dessous
c'était creux donc on a ouvert
au marteau-piqueur ici pour trouver sous
la dalle béton un espace creux qui mène
un escalier
après 15 ans de déblayage un escalier et
un premier niveau apparaissent 4 mètres
plus bas
alors cet espace c'était une cave bien
sûr et c'est une cave qui avait été
remblayé
certainement à la fin du 19e siècle
une salle de 60 mètres carrés et un
superbe puits alors on est devant un
puits qui avait été condamné puisque
à partir du 19e siècle on va plus
utiliser les puits en ville ils sont
pollués on a l'eau distribué grâce au
château d'eau et donc le puits va servir
à évacuer les latrines puisqu'on est
dans la pièce qui a été condamnée là
pour envoyer les latrines les saletés de
la maison
Isabelle persiste elle déblaye encore et
encore pour atteindre un deuxième niveau
à -8 mètres elle trie les gravats avec
un but atteindre le volume d'origine il
y a deux choses différentes soit il y a
des caves qui sont bien sous la maison
et qui sont les fondations de la maison
ou bien on a des réseaux effectivement
mais qui sont indépendants des
constructions qu'il y a au dessus donc
les réseaux ce sont des anciennes
carrières souterraines comme ici dans le
sous-sol de son voisin vous voyez sous
l'escalier ici une trappe
et
4 mètres plus bas
on a un réseau de souterrain
à quelques mètres de là l'ancienne
archevêché connu des Béruriers comme
l'ancienne mairie
autre cave autre découverte alors on est
dans des caves qui ont été réaménagés au
moment de l'occupation en 39-45 en
souterrains de défense passive en fait
en cave de défense passive alors ça
c'est des brancards effectivement qui
pouvaient être utilisé donc en cas
d'attaque en cas d'alerte et il y en a
un petit peu il y en a plusieurs dans
Bourges dans différentes caves qui ont
été réaménagées comme celle-ci pour que
chaque population que tous les habitants
et un lieu où se réfugier en cas
d'attaque aérienne
alors là on est dans la partie bétonnée
la plus récente finalement donc ça c'est
pendant l'occupation toujours qui a eu
un réaménagement de ces souterrains de
ces caves après une cinquantaine de
mètres on retrouvait à nouveau une
partie moyenneuse on sait que les
archéologues de la communauté
d'agglomération à Bourges plus travail
justement font un travail scientifique
actuellement pour retrouver les usages
de ces souterrains de ces caves en tout
cas et éventuellement de l'extraction de
la pierre un travail de recherche et
d'histoire avec comme support les
cartographies des vestiges souterrains
de bourdalous au 19e siècle ou plus
récemment la thèse de Marie Lafont qui
détaille les 2500 ans d'histoire de la
ville de Bourges et de ses cavités
médiévales